hi everyone welcome to cloud on air live
webinars from Google cloud we are
hosting webinars every Tuesday and my
name is Chester Louie and I will be
talking about protecting your work force
with Chrome Enterprise you can ask
questions anytime on this platform and
we have Googlers on standby to answer
them so this presentation is really
broken down into three sections in the
first section we will discuss some
industry insights and trends by cyber
security and show both how businesses
are impacted in the second session we
will talk about the security benefits of
Chrome OS bundled with enterprise
features unlocked by the chrome
Enterprise license that can help your
company state safe in the third and
final section we will take a look at
Google and how it keeps its own business
secure from malicious threats and with
that let's get started with the growing
media reports of state-sponsored
espionage financial crime and tampering
with elections and other malicious
behaviors cybercrime has moved to the
forefront of the current news cycle this
has not only become a concern for
individuals but for businesses of all
shapes and sizes as well we face new
challenges and we have to keep our
businesses secure headlines like these
not only show well-publicized hacks that
have resulted in significant losses they
reiterate the need for businesses to
revisit their cybersecurity strategy IT
administrators have more complexity to
manage as business demands evolve they
have to defend against external attacks
in internal vulnerabilities while
keeping the business moving with the
prevalence of increasing affordability
of cloud computing mobile devices and
connectivity technology in the work
environment is vastly different from
what it used to be on average let's take
a look an employee typically has three
devices to do their job
many of which are not tethered to the
desk and can be used outside of the
office the average employee also has
about 22 cloud apps that are installed
many of which have not been approved by
IT administrators as a result security
concerns are greater than ever as there
are more and more points of attacks and
leakage ninety-eight percent of Fortune
500 companies were affected by malware
in 2017 and as a result of that 69
percent of those were affected by
phishing so workers are also highly
targeted for phishing and malware
attacks Google has conducted research
and has shown that enterprise users are
6.2 times more likely to be targeted for
phishing attacks and 4.3 times more
likely to receive malware than typical
end users given the sheer rate of
enterprises in its employees as targeted
by phishing and malware threats it's
important to implement a strategy that
to tears falling prey to these attacks
not only our cyber attacks affecting
proprietary company data but it's also
becoming a large financial burden
current estimates show that the global
cost of data breaches will reach two
point one trillion by the end of 2019
according to these cyber security
ventures 2017 cybercrime report
hackers are not only looking to cash in
on data they're collecting account
passwords they're finding new ways to
hold data hostage and attacks like
ransomware data on end-user machines are
encrypted by a malicious party only to
be decrypted with a payment ransomware
attacks have increased 15 times since
2015 along with this employees continue
to be vulnerable to attacks which are
increasing and becoming more complex
according to the Willis Towers Watson
cyber
survey in 2017 90% of all reported
breaches were caused by employee
negligence with the increasing number of
sophisticated back actors along with the
growing numbers of vulnerable employees
these numbers could continue to be on
the rise so with the shift targeting
increasing and complexity amongst the
cyber security environment IT has to
find solutions and preventative measures
to handle the risks associated with
enterprise threats a solution to
consider for this changing cybersecurity
landscape is Chrome Enterprise chrome
Enterprise provides solutions fit for
the workplace of the future we provide a
secure consistent user experience across
a range of devices that can be used
anywhere with Chrome OS and granular
controls and enterprise features with
the Chrome Enterprise license when it
comes to security chrome Enterprise
follows three pillars proactive
protections evolving defenses and
granular policies these three buckets
come together to tell a really
compelling story about how chrome
enterprise approaches security in an
entirely different way Chrome OS follows
a multi-layered interlocking approach to
proactively protecting data on the
device from the hardware to the firmware
to the operating system to the
applications and ultimately the browser
level all layers of the Chromebook are
working together to provide a secure
computing experience so like I
highlighted earlier starting at the
hardware level every Chromebook comes
with a Google designed hardware security
module that is tamper resistant and
encrypts all the data on the device at
the firmware level verified boot ensures
that the operating system has not been
tampered with by an untrusted
Chromebooks are unique because we have
two versions of Chrome OS on the device
at all times so if one version is
detected to have been tampered with the
Chromebook will attempt to boot the
other version of the operating system on
the device now let's take a look at the
operating system level OS updates and
patches happen in the background thus
ensuring no downtime while your
employees are getting up to date since
there are two versions of the operating
system on a Chromebook the version that
is not being used by the end-user will
be updated in than a background to
prevent interruption only to be booted
up upon the next machine start no more
employees pressing ignore on update
prompts Chrome OS also stores most user
data securely encrypted in the cloud
rather than locally on the device this
removes the need to protect it on the
local device thus removing the threat
lastly at the application level Google
Play protect ensures that the
applications distributed in Google Play
are not malicious we'll talk about more
about this in a bit so if you look at
the overall value proposition all of
these benefits come stock on Chrome OS
devices to ensure a highly secure
computing experience Chrome OS also
comes with Chrome browser and all of its
security benefits which come on all
devices with Chrome browser
no matter the operating system in 2017
we had two security engineering firms
developed two white papers to examine
the relative security strengths of the
three most popular enterprise browser
Chrome browser Microsoft edge in
Microsoft Internet Explorer the research
of these firms have found that Chrome
browser was able to detect more phishing
sites than edge due to our safe browsing
technology actually 83% to 76% the
research also determined that Chrome
browser was the quickest of the three
browsers to patch major security bugs
next I want to talk about our solution
against phishing attacks Chromebooks in
conjunction with security keys and Safe
Browsing make G suite users secure
against these types of attacks first
security keys security keys are
supported by G suite and provide a
second requirement for authenticating
into your account the security key is a
piece of hardware that can be plugged
directly into for example the USB port
on your device and ensure that even if
your password is obtained by a malicious
party they would still need the security
key to login secondly let's talk about
Safe Browsing Safe Browsing warns users
of malicious threats before they
actually happen so if a site is detected
to be a phishing site for example the
end user will be prompted to steer clear
and turn away finally and as discussed
in previous slides Chromebooks offer
background updates this ensures end
users are always up to date with the
with the patches and the most recent
vulnerability patches onboard their
devices and the browser next let's
discuss Chrome Enterprise license the
chrome enterprise license unlocks a
collection of enterprise features and
granular management that help IT
administrators manage a large fleet of
devices with over 200 plus policies all
of this plugs into a legacy
infrastructure and deploys and allows
administrators to deploy applications to
their end-users with user based policies
IT administrators can ensure that
employee employees are compliant
regardless of which Chrome device they
are using with device based policies IT
administrators can ensure devices adhere
to strict protocols regardless of which
user is accessing them with chrome
enterprise licensing IT administrators
can also manage applications and
extensions and distribute them in a
curated list based on an end-user group
and lastly what fleet management
commands IT administrators can easily
provision monitor and lock down devices
at the touch of a button the Google
admin console is a cloud-based device
management portal this capability to
manage Chrome browser and OS started
over six years ago and we're even more
excited to announce that we are
partnering with third-party enterprise
mobility management providers to give
you an even more flexible and broader
easier access to security features we
just announced a partnership with VMware
AirWatch last year making them the first
third-party EMM solution to manage
Chromebooks we also just announced new
partnerships with Cisco Meraki Citrix
Zen mo Mille in IBM Mass 360 and there
are many more to come we also have
integrated Chrome OS with Active
Directory to allow customers to enjoy
the benefits of Chrome within their ad
infrastructure for those of you who are
unaware select chrome OS devices support
the Google Play Store bringing the most
popular mobile app ecosystem to
Chromebooks with managed Google Play IT
administrators can curate application
lists for employees and even have
different lists for different groups one
of the major benefits of using Google
Play as an application distribution
distribution mechanism is the malware
detection that happens on the server
side Google Play has a feature called
googleplay protect this group this
offering scans over 50 billion apps
every day to ensure malware is not
detected as a result of this over 2
billion devices are protected by Google
Play protect by using applications sign
to be indeed to be safe now to our final
section let's take a look at how Google
thinks about application access control
and keeps itself secure when it comes to
protecting its data Google is considered
three areas to ensure properly security
measures that are put into place the
first bucket our users we need to ensure
that the right users have the right
level of access to get their jobs done
the second bucket is applications
applications provide access to data that
potentially not all employees can have
access to and the third bucket is
devices Google's considers this deeply
when determining when an employee can
have access what types of devices are
employees accessing from and also is the
device a corporate issued device Google
ultimately needs a solution for tech
detecting this type of scenario so when
you combine these three things you
leverage a methodology called beyond
Corp width which is essentially tiered
access in a tiered access model policies
are set at a corporate level so internal
services are classified by trusted tier
user credentials for example are
verified when resources requests are
made from specific devices given this
information access to data and
applications are granted if the risk
profile of the end user and device
matches the trust here Google has
moved away from perimeter based security
an ip-based trust what this gives you is
an employee that could connect to the
internet from anywhere in the world
without a VPN and be able to access his
or her applications there are three
primary beyond core principles the first
one connecting from a particular network
must not determine which services you
can access the second is access to
services is granted based on what we
know about you and your device and the
third all access to services must be
authenticated authorized and encrypted
to provide a simplified example consider
the use case of various employees at
Google an employee may only require a
low tier of access to retrieve access
for example to the cafeteria menu
they don't need access to more sensitive
services like the HR portal assigning
the lowest tier of access required to
complete a request has several
advantages it decreases the maintenance
of costs associated with highly secured
devices and also improves the usability
of the device as a device is allowed to
access more sensitive data we require
more frequent tests of user presence on
the device so the more we trust a given
device the shorter lived its credentials
so the wrapped us up there are three
major takeaways end points are critical
to cloud security more devices and
applications are being used by employees
from more locations than ever before
driving malicious actors with more
sophisticated hacks this creates a new
security paradigm for businesses who
ultimately need the right strategy and
tools to keep their business safe
security at the browser device an OS
level is essential Chrome Enterprise
provides a secure entry point to the
cloud with Chrome OS and the enterprise
features and tools you need to ensure
employees are compliant with the Chrome
enterprise license and finally trust
endpoints and apps enable a tiered
access strategy at Google we focus on a
tiered access strategy for users
applications and devices to ensure data
is secured and always secure if you like
to learn more about chrome enterprise
solutions for Chrome OS you can go to
enterprise at google.com slash chrome
slash contact and a representative will
be in touch with you shortly
if you'd like to learn more about chrome
enterprise solutions for Chrome browser
you can go to chrome comm slash
enterprise will stay online for a few
more minutes to continue to answer
questions as they come in thank you very
much and I hope you found that this
information was very helpful
you
welcome everybody back to the live Q&A
so we've got a couple of questions here
from the audience so let's run through
some of these questions right now first
question that's live is how come there
are five EMS that were chosen to
integrate with Chrome enterprise so I
highlighted in the earlier presentation
that there are five current EMS that
have been enabled and also partnered
with to basically integrate and manage
Chrome OS devices currently we're not
limited to these five there will be
additional partnerships as a result of
this but these were the first five
partners that actually engaged with us
to go live so we expect actually more
partnerships to formulate as a result of
this second question is do I need a
chrome enterprise license to use
Chromebooks within my Microsoft Active
Directory deployment so the answer to
that is yes you do you you will need to
actually you know first off you can
actually sign up for a trial and then
secondly if if you wish to proceed you
can actually get an actual chrome
enterprise license and it would actually
be an annual subscription license this
typically the MSRP and the associated
costs with that is believe fifty dollars
a year and that actually supports the
Microsoft Active Directory Integration
with Chrome OS devices let's see so we
have some other additional questions how
much does the chrome enterprise license
cost that's a really good question
so the typical cost for chrome
enterprise licensing again is $50 a year
it's a subscription-based annual
offering and also let's see there's
there's one more question that's coming
up live here is is Chrome OS and
Enterprise part of Google Cloud or
separate to the kugel division so Chrome
Enterprise actually sits underneath the
Google Cloud umbrella so Chrome
Enterprise is actually part of the
Google cloud organization and team so
with that thanks so much for watching
please tune in on Tuesday June 5th for
the next cloud on-air